[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
presbyterian beat saint andrews over the
weekend you might not have noticed
although presbyterian's quarterback a
michigan transfer through ten touchdown
passes and the reason why the game
caught our eye is the head coach at
presbyterian is kevin kelly and we
covered this story a couple of years ago
where coach never punted i don't even
know if he has a punter on his team and
uh we thought okay made his college
debut and certainly uh made an impact
with 84-43 win over st andrews and coach
joins us
you gave up 43 points though coach i
mean 84 you scored but you still gave up
43.
no we we did we've got a lot of work to
do on both sides to be honest but our
games are kind of like that because
we shorten the field a lot if we don't
make a fourth down in a bad spot the
field shorter if we on sidekick don't
get it the field's shorter so it it
usually ends up a little higher scoring
games do you have a puncher on your
squad
there was one here when i came and he
transferred
i know that was
people always ask me what was going to
happen if i became a college coach i'd
never i thought it was always a joke and
then it really kind of happened
butter transfer
okay but did did have you changed
anything since you've gone from high
school to college
no no you know i mean and think about it
you know you've moved up in the world if
you change anything that got you there
you feel like if it goes bad you'll be
always mad at yourself like
you know i didn't do what got me here
and you know i think all the success and
i think i've got math and science behind
it i think it proved it so i was going
to do what i believe in because isn't
that what we're supposed to do for our
guys on the field make the decisions we
believe in it gives them the best chance
but
uh what was the reaction when you did
this in high school like when you
people realize you weren't going to punt
yeah i mean at first there were some
booze from our own crowd
and then you know and then there was you
know the media was writing bad things
about it and negative and there was a
lot of naysayers and then you know as we
started winning those kind of went away
and then i had to deal with the coaches
because i would go to coaches clinics
and coaches would sit away from me like
i had leprosy or something because they
were like you're making a mockery of our
game and i'm like i'm just trying to win
at a school that had never won anything
you know and and i have to do something
different because i think i'm a good
football coach i think i'm really good
at some things but
you know if you can find an advantage
somewhere else even if it's just a
little one here and there those add up i
call it the casino theory a one and a
half percent advantage in blackjack and
a 0.8 in craps
and they always win so if we can do that
and give ourselves a little edge by just
making better decisions and it works so
i fought them at first and i thought the
media would be the worst part and you
guys are the ones that actually made it
okay to do because when some media guys
started doing positive spins on it
the social side came over and they're
like okay they like it we like it so
it's not nearly as bad now give me the
analytics behind not punting
you know really you should punt some in
theory and according to the numbers
themselves but
field position and expected points and i
won't bore you with with all the the
real true analytics of the game but
people should punt a lot less in the
game than they do now i mean it's just
proven even at times on your own into
the field in the first quarter of the
game and those kinds of things and and
i've decided not to do that but the more
i did it and and i saw that
we were punting so little at one time
when i was at first experimenting that
it was a waste of time to waste 15
minutes a day on the puck team in that
15 minutes i got to work on something
else that we needed to on offense or
defense well they don't measure that in
the analytics world
so
you should really punt if you value
those 15 minutes a day even
you should punt even less than the
numbers say
you've heard from other coaches very
successful coaches uh who came in to
pick your brain
i mean i mean
a lot a lot of people and a lot of them
asked me not to name them so i'm kind of
scared but but it's been a who's who
like bill belichick
well you know bill bill and i bill just
likes talking football i don't think
he's ever going to go the no punt route
don't get me wrong but he's curious
though
yeah i mean i think i think i think
curious i think you know you know we
i think he likes to be around people
that are successful
and he sees certain things and and maybe
he was just
i don't know if curious is the thing but
we've talked some football and i'll
guarantee you this i've learned a lot
more from him than he has for me but
he's watched our games and watched what
we do and i think he's trying to see
maybe some of the psychological effects
that it has on the teams as well as as
well as what it looks like but i think
that's there's a lot of coaches that
have done that but i've had some of the
biggest names
in coaching you know nick saban told me
at one point um and i don't think nick
minds that i mention his name because
he's nick he can do whatever he wants to
but he looked and he said i think you're
probably right more than you're wrong
but it's hard to do that because of of
all the things you have to face and
you'd have to win your team over that
traditionally think a different way
and and he was winning anyway so what
you know why would he change anything
but do you think this might
hamper you in getting promoted moving up
the ladder in college
absolutely absolutely and it's hampered
me so far i've had i've interviewed for
a lot of jobs you know whether it's a
coordinator or or a head coach or even a
position coach and it doesn't stop the
positions but you know the the athletic
director always thinks if i hire the
wrong football coach and we know this to
be true dad
he might get fired
and the other thing they don't want to
deal with and i've been told by athletic
directors they don't want to deal with
the media that comes along with it
if you do lose a game and make a
decision that they think
is non-traditional then they've got to
answer questions too and a lot of them
don't want to do that so yeah it
absolutely might hamper me but again it
goes back to this
i think a football coach's job besides
knowing football and facilitating the
relationships and coaching is when it
comes to the moment are you making the
decision you think is best for your team
or so you don't have to deal with the
media or have to deal with not moving up
in the profession and i just decided a
long time ago my job is to do the
decision that's going to help us win
games because those guys deserve the
reward of all the hard work the players
the assistant coaches the fans because
they pay to see it so i went that route
and if it happens it happens if it
doesn't it doesn't if you coached in the
nfl
would you punt
you know i've pun you know it's not that
i never punt we've put it eight times in
the last 16 years
oh wow okay
i know it's not but there are times to
punt so the answer is we may punt this
year some we may punt you know but but
yes i'm sure there would be times i'd
punt the nfl there would be a lot less
than what anybody else is doing
well let's say it's fourth and ten at
your own twenty
first quarter no score
first quarter no score
who's my quarterback
the same guy who threw for ten
touchdowns over the weekend oh yeah no
i'm not i'm probably i'm probably not
playing okay because i feel like we've
got a good offensive scheme too that
i've got a good chance to make 10 yards
a better chance than another team
you're facing my alma mater in a couple
of weeks
who's that dayton
oh nice yeah
i'm excited about that i hope they don't
make us punt they have some great punt
returners on that dating team
[Laughter]
again look at that we're eliminating
this game making that out of play
can you
can you schedule anybody like a big-name
school i'm looking at what what you have
here uh
any chances of getting
i don't know
clemson you're insane
they've played clemson they've played
alabama in the last i think in the last
10 years yeah and you know the schedule
was made when i got here but that's one
of the first things i asked the athletic
directors that next time we get a spot
to open up if we can besides the money
because we're we're a tiny we're the
smallest division one school in the
country
besides that and the money you get from
we don't have any money so we can use
that but so i told them i want to
because even kids i've had that have
gone on to colleges like i had a
quarterback that played at kent state
and he played he started four years
there and he went and played at alabama
and they just got killed as you would
imagine 55 to six or something like that
but if you ask him what game he
remembers the most it's i got to play in
tuscaloosa so everybody's like well
they'll get beat up physically well i
coach that part of the game different
too get out of bounds don't get hit
be healthy for the next game but they'll
remember that game and and and that
gives those guys some memories and some
talk that they get to play and and i
don't think it hurts recruiting either
you're not afraid of anybody
no no and i teams i don't think want to
play us because they don't want to deal
with the not punting they don't want to
do all the onside kicks and those kinds
of things
well good luck it's great to talk to you
kev and uh good luck with uh the
upcoming season
i appreciate you having me on this is a
bucket list thing i got to check another
thing off the bucket list because the
great game of football well it's like
going to tuscaloosa and facing nick
saban
yeah i would like to do that too now it
might not end as well
yeah thank you coach we appreciate your
time
thanks dan i appreciate it that's uh
kevin kelly he coaches at presbyterian
they host fort lauderdale this saturday
and of course they had the big win i'm
ready to play for him yeah i totally go
play for him it sounds sounds like all
right i'm i'm i'm interested in this
yeah mclellan what kind of coward would
punt the football